I do you someday as a chariot words are
these words that would seem as though
tarik say to in this culture said the
you the North American of us come true
um and that's partly of course because
the hiberno-english that I was brought
up and you know it's users it's just a
different language and it uses I
mentioned earlier if I mentioned earlier
that there's still vestiges of she
experienced in lish where I was brought
up and you know that's that's a language
it's not much used in North America
though funnily enough there are probably
more examples of it you know
fossilization in the might moons you
know Virginia and the Carolinas than one
might imagine so
there are words that are indeed not much
used in this culture and now I can see
how people would be forgiven for
thinking that I go out of my way to use
these arcane ish words but I I suppose I
would say AG what am I where to use the
right word the word that's appropriate
and I said you know I just I happen to
be interested in language and I suppose
I have but I'm a guy who you know in the
bookstore will hand not necessarily not
at all actually for the novel's first
but you know to the to the oddities
section you know to the section that
includes all those books on how the
language came to being and the
etymologies of words and all that sort
of stuff I just love that I don't always
have and I mean I suppose for some
people that may seem strange I don't
that's what I think you know William
Safire is common column seems to me to
be an indicator actually that a lot of
people are interested in such matters I
think we're we're interested in the
language we use certainly many of us are
so it's true
funnily enough I had an email yesterday
from some random person saying you know
I read your poor poor me yours on your
website why don't you write some
ordinary poems that the rest of us can't
understand just so you know of course
what would love to be able to do that as
a matter of course and that's when I set
out to do I suppose and insofar as I
said I'd to do anything but you know
what it doesn't always work out that way
it really doesn't and I suppose you know
I would love it if Einstein not that I'm
comparing myself to him you know could
sort of simplify his theory for me or
you know as a thing things are there are
things about the world that are complex
and in fact almost everything in the
world is complex you know beginning with
the machinery that we're using to record
this it's very complex you know I'm
moving then to one's mobile phone not to
speak of one's watch not to speak of
one's person I mean the body is a very
complex thing that we don't understand
but we have failed to explain and in a
profile in any significant way there's
so much that we don't understand about
it
we understand nothing to speak off of
the universe nothing to speak of except
some of these broad gestures right so it
seems to me that to ask for a poetry
light as it were it's a very very
understandable urge it is it's a very
understandable urge and it's one that
poets themselves are taken by because
one does want some kind of clarification
in the midst of it all however momentary
it might be that's what one's after some
modest momentary clarification but we
we're after that because we realize that
part of that clarification actually
illuminates the complexity that
surrounds it and sometimes the
clarification itself must contain
something of that complexity and we know
indeed that sometimes the poems that
seem most simple the ones that we
remember the ones that we go back to
every time we go back to them we realize
actually they're not so simple at all so
there's a very this is a this is a is a
big topic it's a big job